yeah I'm just going to make some copies
in
here perfect cover nailed it so
apparently the new captain survived and
his heart attack not the craziest thing
that happened at the precinct
today we kissed like 3 hours ago yes we
did kiss each other for reals reals
reals listen I know you said you don't
want to take cops but I really like you
I like you too good but what if we start
dating and it makes things weird at work
so let's just keep it light and Breezy
see where it goes totally yeah so how do
we keep it light and Breezy I know a
comprehensive set of rules how am I
attracted to you doesn't matter I am go
rule one let's not tell anyone so we can
figure out what this is first smort rule
number two let's not put labels on it
we're not boyfriend and girlfriend we're
just Merm Zep and jingle bin Great rule
number three let's not have sex right
away
cool cool
cool Ames you're 2 minutes late I called
all the emergency rooms I know I went
home from your place to shower and I'm
so tired that I fell asleep while
shaving my legs but we went to bed so
early Property Brothers was over at 10 I
mean sex we do it she's tired from all
the doing
it there you are thank God hey how'd you
find me January 14th 2014 detectives
Peralta in Santiago conducted
surveillance from a rooftop at 397
Barton Street this is where we came the
night I won our bet and you fell in love
with me Jake the night that you flirted
with me for 20 seconds and I became
obsessed with you forever
ready I'm sorry I freaked out and ran
away it's okay just because you messed
up the practice test doesn't mean you're
going to fail the real one I didn't mess
it up I got 102% I found a spelling
error in one question I gave myself
extra credit then why' you leave because
that was the first time it really hit me
when I pass the exam I'll actually be a
sergeant what if everything changes
between us that's why you came here yeah
things are so good right now I don't
want to screw that up by getting
transferred or becoming your boss Ames
I've always known you were going to be
my boss I mean this is your dream from
before we were dating and yeah things
might change a little but for the better
right can finally get premium cable
check out all those shows on epics
look you can't be afraid to be
successful you're too good for that I
love you love you
too wait the test we got to get you out
of here right I'm going to be a sergeant
you're going to be a
[Music]
sergeant you don't have a key for this
random roof door do you it's called taxi
because it's yellow and it takes you
where you need to be drug dealers have
gotten so creative they used to just be
crack and then they be like hey we got a
new one what are we going to call this
and they'd go I don't know crank this is
certainly worth following up on Santiago
take boil and work the case oh but Jake
I mean detective Peralta brought in the
per so good point uh Peralta and boil
can work the case actually sir I think
we were kind of hoping we could work the
case together oh are you two no longer
smushing booties yes that's exactly how
I was going to finish my sentence
figured we are still dating it's all
above board HR gets daily updates and
rbcc on all our emails to each other
that's why HR Jim keeps high-fiving We
Begin where all great stories begin in
the qut little town of french fry
Village after that we're going to move
our adventure over to Cheeseburger
Mountain which consists you guested it
of turkey burgers I'm kidding it's
cheeseburgers this is kind of just
stuffing you can avoid that but it's
attached to the Thanksgiving turkey
theme cuz I was thinking about that a
lot up in the jail and finally we have a
big old Passover brisket cuz you know I
loves my mom if you would all take a
seat while I make a
toast kindly raise your two lers
to freedom to you and most importantly
to Orange drank and sex with Amy to sex
with Amy sorry should have said that
last
part hey honey thanks for bringing Roger
back you're very welcome hey by the way
Amy was really nervous to meet you so
don't judge her too harshly for all the
weird singing oh no I'm dating my son of
a ex-husband who am I to
judge I think she's really
great I think you're really great too
she's very good at lip reading I
wouldn't say I'm very good I mean deaf
people they're the real
talents just can't stop I'll let you
guys talk I'll just close my
eyes he's leaving our plan worked we
saved our own honeymoon and fun bonus we
cheered up halt yes okay it's time to
celebrate you know what that means this
bee needs a c and her a oh my God this
babe needs a coconut in her arms Oh I
thought you were saying this needs a
oh my God yeah that was my reaction all
right I'll go get us a couple of
coconuts I kept thinking how did anyone
swap my key and then it hit me they
didn't they swapped the safe one of the
handmaids I'm assuming fake Charles took
my safe and then of Amy deposited a
lookalike what did you give fake Charles
so he'd help you nothing in fact he gave
me something the power of Financial
Freedom I invested in a pyramid scheme
it's no time to go into it right now
okay so while we all tried to figure out
who had the real key fake Charles broke
into the safe remove the tracker and let
Terry and the whole squad on a wild
goose chase my only question is which
box is the belt in well good luck
figuring it out because the clock is
Tick Tick talking it's that one no the
dust pattern on top doesn't match its
neighbors you see Jake I'm always going
to be one step ahead of you you've lost
the ability to surprise me you're just
plain boring again weird take on a very
loving relationship and it's midnight so
I guess I'm an amazing human SL genius
yeah
although you might want to read the
inscription on that there Bel why oh no
what does it say Amy Santiago will you
marry
me
surprise I'm so confused I don't know
what's happening right now I'm so
confused I don't know what's happening
right now title your sex tape oh my God
I'm shaking I'm definitely going to cry
title of your sex tape wait is this
really happening is this part of the if
this is part of the heist I will dump
you so hard no please as look it's
really happening okay it's not part of
the heist I promise this is you are I
love how beautiful you are I love your
face and I love your butt I should have
written this down first no no it's okay
go on I love how much you pretend to
like die hard I like the second one you
don't have to okay yeah you're kind and
you're funny and you're the best person
I know
and the best
detective
also for reals I love your butt I love
yours too
gross Amy
Santiago will you marry me Jake Peralta
I will marry
you I love you so much hey jeros this
little escapes so that ought to
teach did you just mhm and did you
mhm hey Gina just texted me she said
weird I didn't even realize they were
dating JK so happy for you so
Jake tell us everything did you call
Amy's dad first I actually did Mr
Santiago I'm calling to inform you that
I plan to ask your daughter to marry me
but since it's 2017 I am not asking for
your permission as she is not your
property nor would she be mine if she
chooses to say yes she's a strong
independent woman and she don't need no
man that being said I truly hope she
says yes but it's her decision so just
back off aw that was perfect what did he
say I have no idea I left a voicemail
I'm terrified of him not to talk out of
turn but I think I get credit for giving
Jake the idea to propose how's that
remember a day in the kitchen so what
I'm saying is vanilla yogurt is good but
pair it with a blueberry yogurt and both
of them taste even better get
it yes I did not get it but speaking of
yogurt you've eaten six GPS devices this
week you should definitely see a doctor
what m look Serge I think everyone knows
that I planted the idea in Jake's head
eight years ago oh hi I'm starting today
detective Santiago oh detective fata
welcome aboard I'm hearing Wedding
Bells hi Detective Bo it actually really
slowed things down it took like 4 years
for me to forget that memory yeah I'm My
Own Worst Enemy look no one gave me the
idea I decided to ask Amy to marry me
all on my own on April
28th there's a typo in this crossw word
puzzle
I don't get it seems pretty normal I
don't know what to tell you that's just
what I knew romantic epiphanies are dope
thank you Rosa please be
seated friends colleagues gawking New
Yorkers we are here today to celebrate
the marriage of Jake Peralta and Amy
Santiago I've known you both for the
last 5 years and it has been a true
pleasure to watch your distracting
childish rivalry evolve into into a
distracting childish courtship and now
into what I'm sure will be a distracting
childish
marriage I'm proud of you and I love you
both permission to say it back
permission granted love you you sir love
you